hey youtubers it's Charlie and guardians
of the galaxy totally just found its
Rocket Raccoon so I thought it was time
to do a big update for the movie there
was even a giant fake trailer that was
floating around recently so as you can
see from my picture here kind of
telegraphed the reveal Bradley Cooper
has been offered the role as Rocket
Raccoon obviously he'll be the voice of
Rocket Raccoon and so any Bradley Cooper
you see in the movie will be very fuzzy
with a very pointy face you'll have to
let me know what you think in the
comments of the idea of a Bradley Cooper
Rocket Raccoon obviously if you've been
reading the comics that you know that
the characters right action based he
wheels these two giant guns so the
Bradley Cooper that we see in this movie
we'll probably be shouting his dialogue
over a gunfire he also lends a lot more
star power to the movie like Glenn Close
or Benicio del Toro so that's kind of
exciting but honestly I think that
Marvel is probably going to have to
pitch shipped his voice up just a little
bit because actually Rocket Raccoon is a
very small character and he basically
runs around with kuru this was a really
tall character and some of the comedy
between those two characters has to do
with the contrast and even though I
didn't get a chance to do a video for
Vin Diesel's Groot
obviously yes he is playing Groot so
that's going to be very interesting what
do you think about that too obviously so
think about Bradley Cooper and Vin
Diesel now obviously Bradley Cooper's
character is a wisecracker so he'll be
talking quite a bit there'll be a lot of
dialogue from him but Groot actually in
the comic books only says his name so do
you think that because Vin Diesel is
such a big actors that they'll fudge on
that and let him speak regularly
obviously that's a bit of a departure
from the character in the comic books
but it kind of allows them to use a big
actor like Vin Diesel a little bit more
doesn't it just seems silly to cast
someone as big as Vin Diesel and not let
him talk even though you don't really go
in to say like a Vin Diesel movie
thinking about dialogue I feel like it
is kind of silly to cast someone as big
as him and not giving them any lines let
me know what you think the Vin Diesel
Bradley Cooper are kicking ass together
obviously the characters spend a lot of
time together in the comic books so I
expect that to kind of carry over into
the movie and do you think they can be
funny together the characters there's a
lot of comedy surrounding them in the
comic books obviously Bradley Cooper has
a history of doing a lot of comedy films
but do you think that Vin Diesel can be
funny as a motion-capture character I'm
still kind of waiting though for the
first
pictures of a green zoe saldana to start
circulating obviously she's just that
right mixture of really good-looking and
really tough originally I was actually
kind of worried when they started
announcing the cast but then you know
they announced Chris Pratt Lee pays
Benicio del Toro there's a lot of good
actors in this film and everyone I've
been talking to really feels like it's
it's going to be those bunkers amazing
movie you've ever seen and it'll kind of
turn the superhero action genre on its
head a little bit but we'll have to wait
a little bit to find out just because
the first official footage probably
won't come until the Thor movie
premieres in November but let me know
what you're most excited about it but
this guardians of the galaxy movie I
mean you're excited about Karen Gillan
and all you Doctor Who fans out there
Lee pace Glenn Close as Nova prime
Benicio del Toro or Chris Pratt in the
Guardians honestly I think they're all
going to be amazing so I'm really
looking forward to the movie but
honestly I really want to see some more
footage please send for footage so I'll
be doing tons more Marvel videos this
fall and I'll be doing weekly agents of
shield videos once the show starts in
September be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos I'll probably also
include a lot of stuff from the Marvel
movies and those recaps too just because
there's a little bit of crossover in the
meantime you can click here to watch my
Peter Jackson Doctor Who video that's
right Peter Jackson's coming to Doctor
Who it's gonna be crazy and bonkers or
we can click here to watch my review of
the Kit Harington Pompeii trailer let's
just say there's a lot of abs thanks so
much for watching see you tomorrow high
fives